se empezó preguntando por su lectura
sobre la irrupción del Social demócrata
Bernardo Arévalo que no partía entre Los
favoritos en las encuestas ni mucho
menos le pregunto si hubo un error una
falta de leer una voluntad de cambio
entre la población
sí quisiera iniciar primero corrigiendo
un poco Sandra Torres no es una persona
que se identifica bajo la centro derecha
es posiblemente el único partido
guatemalteco que está inscrito en la
internacional socialista Entonces en
realidad estamos en una disputa para la
segunda ronda con dos opciones de
izquierda o socialdemócratas verdad de
Centro izquierda es histórico lo que
logró Bernardo Arévalo porque por mucho
tiempo los analistas y me incluyo
asumimos que la única forma para poder
asegurarse una victoria en las
elecciones generales de Guatemala o por
lo menos pasará a segunda vuelta
requeríamos de tres cosas uno campañas
millonarias dos tener una exposición
alta dentro de los canales de televisión
abierta verdad que son los canales que
llegan a todos los hogares de los
guatemaltecos y tres el beneplácito o el
o el agrado de las élites económicas del
país temía no tiene ninguna de esas tres
Y de alguna u otra forma logró colarse a
la segunda vuelta
y María de los quisiera preguntarle de
hecho por lo que usted me comentaba y
gracias por esta corrección porque de
hecho me parece un tema un poco confuso
no exactamente la posición ideológica de
Sandra Torres Que bueno está Gracias por
comentarnos lo inscrita a la
internacional a la socialista pero sin
embargo ha tenido opiniones muy
favorables al modelo por ejemplo
securitario de nayib bukele no y por eso
algunos analistas comentan que está
mirando en ciertos aspectos a la derecha
pero Precisamente lo que le quiero
preguntar es que si bien entre los tres
favoritos ella era la que menos la
derecha estaba ahora respecto a Arévalo
está más a la derecha que él no Por
decirlo así entonces cómo se van a
realinear las opciones políticas
Sí claro habría que explicar que la une
sufre de una transición en los últimos
tres procesos electorales que son los
procesos electorales en donde ha
participado ya Sandra Torres es la
tercera vez que ella se postula como
candidata A diferencia de Bernardo
Arévalo que es la primera vez y cuando
fue electo el partido une por primera
vez a la presidencia su identificación
ideológica era social demócrata conforme
los años y conforme los procesos pues ha
ido
moviendo o mudándose a un espectro mucho
más centro mucho más centro derecha y
efectivamente si ha demostrado afinidad
ante las políticas de nayib bukele sobre
todo en temas de seguridad no obstante
los programas sociales siguen siendo una
gran fortaleza y una gran oferta
política de Sandra Torres a nivel
nacional es importante también Resaltar
de que es uno de los partidos que ha
sido acusado de tener vínculos con el
narcotráfico y el crimen organizado
adicionalmente uno de los grandes
financistas del partido Se declaró
culpable y recientemente por tráfico de
influencias en temas de farmacéuticas y
el sistema de salud guatemalteco pero
definitivamente es una decisión que
dentro para los guatemaltecos que se
identifican como derecha no ven en
ninguno de los dos una opción inmediata
verdad Creo que van a tener que meditar
mucho su voto sobre Qué es el tipo de
gobierno que desean a futuro Porque
entonces a nivel programático Cuáles son
las principales diferencias entre Torres
y Arévalo de Cara a la campaña que vayan
a hacer para la segunda vuelta
claro Hay que también identificar Quién
es el vicepresidenciable de Sandra
Torres es un ex pastor de la comunidad
evangélica iglesia evangélica Y eso le
ha venido muy bien a Sandra Torres para
poder posicionarse dentro del Gran grupo
de conservadores que existen en
Guatemala sobre esos temas que le
preocupan a esa población verdad estamos
hablando de temas de aborto estamos
hablando de la concepción de la familia
tradicional pero en temas específicos de
política pública de Cómo resolver el
tema del alto costo de la vida como
resolver el tema de la inseguridad Yo te
diría que no hay una gran diferencia
entre ambos partidos políticos verdad
Sandra Torres continúa ofreciendo y
duplicando la política de programas
sociales para poder asegurarle a la
gente mejores condiciones sociales pero
no hace una gran propuesta o una gran
reforma a políticas públicas que
efectivamente sí saquen a las personas
de la pobreza y no sean subsidiarios
nada más